starting off this hour as California
chat is calling hi Chad how are you good
how are you doing Dave better than I
deserve sir how can I help I had a
question about a mutual fund I'm just
starting to do the investing part and I
went to a broker and I'm finding some
good mutual funds with the good
percentages like you say with the
front-end load B being about 5% 5 and 35
and 3/4 is what most of them are yeah
yeah yeah I was just wondering if that's
5 whatever you said that five and three
quarter percent is that when you take
you say that 12% return would that mean
that I'm really only getting 7% what's
not five and three-quarter a year it's
five and three-quarter the first time
you put money in okay see I'm still I
don't know everything and I was like
that's okay let's talk through it
there's basically three ways you can get
at this okay there's what are called
loaded mutual funds which are mutual
funds that have a commission and there's
no load mutual funds that don't have a
commission there's two types of ways to
get at the loaded funds let's talk for
it for a minute we'll use you as a
teaching opportunity for all our
listeners is that okay okay yeah you
just walk through me with this and
you're getting questions you interrupt
me as I go okay to start with a no load
fund is not sold through a broker you
buy them directly from a company and
you'll see their advertisements in
magazines and on websites and things
it's companies like Vanguard and
fidelity okay and that they are they are
primarily no-load which means they don't
charge a commission now no Commission
does not always mean cheaper for two
reasons one is there's two or three ways
they charge fees on mutual funds all
mutual funds have a maintenance fee
annually okay okay based on your balance
at that time so let's say you had
$100,000 in there and the maintenance
fee was three quarters of a percent
that'd be seven hundred and fifty
dollars that you were charged as a fee
for maintenance in the mutual fund okay
now a no load mutual fund has a
maintenance fee
so you're still gonna have a fee it just
doesn't have a commission doesn't have
the five and three-quarter or the other
kinds of commissions we're going to talk
about in a few minutes so you do have a
fee now let's say that you let's go back
to our five and three quarters example
okay let's say that you put $100,000
into that fund with that broker and you
paid the commission of five and three
quarters then will that be five thousand
seven hundred fifty dollars right yeah
that you paid upfront now then your
maintenance fee on that fund let's say
it was a quarter of a percent only 250 a
year so for ten years I'd be twenty five
hundred dollars after ten years you
would have paid in maintenance fees two
hundred fifty a year times ten do you
follow that yeah okay and then you'd
have paid the fifty seven hundred on top
of that and so we're talking about seven
thousand bucks and some change over ten
thousand dollars you're following me
yeah over ten you know now the other one
let's pretend it had a I looked at one
the other day that was a no load that I
didn't buy because it was a ripoff I
thought but it had over a one percent
maintenance fee it had a one point two
percent maintenance fee okay so twelve
hundred dollars a year right yeah for
ten years on a hundred thousand that's
twelve thousand dollars Wow okay so you
paid the Commission on the other one but
it was cheaper do you follow me
yeah that's what in my mind I thought oh
if I can go around the broker I'm gonna
make a lot more money but like not but
not if you get one with a high
maintenance fee yeah so you got it you
got to watch they get you on the back if
I don't get you on the front now now
there are good no load funds that have
reasonable maintenance fees and
sometimes I buy a no load fund okay
I'm not against them I'm just warning
you that no Commission does not always
mean cheaper you have to dig a little
deeper to figure that out okay yeah so
that's the first thing then the second
thing is with Commission's there's
basically two ways that people are
charging now one is they're doing the
five and three quarter up front like
you're talking about which are a shares
okay and the second way is that they're
doing what are called
C shares and the brokers will manage
your whole portfolio for you instead of
charging you a commission upfront
they'll do it for 1% a year
okay hey which is not a bad deal because
you got a broker there to advise you and
teach you and help you for every year if
you got a good broker that's involved
and you can call them you know you see a
bad news story about something and
you're worried about the stock market
dropping 400 points last week in one day
and you want to call your broker you got
somebody to talk to and there's actually
research ad that shows that if you have
a good broker in your corner
you tend to make more because you tend
to not make as emotional to the decision
okay that makes sense right there I
guess that's worth it yeah it's worth it
to have a coach there's research that
indicates that lots of it as a matter of
fact so you could do the 1% deal where
they just charge you 1% a year and
there's no Commission but they charge
you 1% fee to manage everything but
they're there at your beck and call if
you need them you know and if you put
want to put more money in there's no fee
except the next year you're gonna get a
1% bill on that money that you put in on
top of everything else you put in but
again
again some people love that and they act
like that the people that charge 5 and 3
some of these people have a holier than
thou thing in the in the financial world
and act like the people charge in five
and three-quarters are ripping somebody
off but let's do the math again because
these are the exact same two mutual
funds just two different ways to charge
it in a commission 1% to manage it or 5
and 3/4 up front so let's take our
hundred thousand again five and three
quarters is five thousand seven hundred
and fifty dollars okay one percent on a
hundred thousand if it doesn't grow at
all which would be bad really bad but if
it doesn't grow at all one percent
$1,000 a year for ten years is ten
thousand dollars so even if you do the
1% with quote no Commission you pay more
okay so better to do the eighth year
yeah as long as you leave it alone but
if you want to buy and sell the funds
inside of there and you want to move
some stuff around later on you know
you're going to pay that stinking 500
every time you move it around so the
truth is
all three of those work and I'm okay if
you do any of the three as long as you
look at them carefully for your
situation and you decide I used to be a
huge proponent only of the five and
three-quarter upfront because of what we
just did but the one percent thing is
fine and the no-load is fine but you're
not holy if you you know some of these
the guys in the financial world of
Pharisees and they're like oh I'm a 1%
guy and so these other guys are ripping
people off with the Commission up front
and then the people who don't want
anybody to ever be charged a commission
or saying anybody who charges a
commissioner ripping people off it's
just not mathematically true you know
okay so yeah I read that online that
yeah there's a budget and I read one on
Forbes today the guy's like anybody
charges a fee is a is a ripoff artist
and there's a used car salesman well
that's just not true there's some of
yeah there's some of them that are but
if you're you know I believe in paying a
real estate agent a good Commission
could usually sell the house faster and
for more money so sometimes the
Commission is worth it you just have to
get somebody a that knows what they're
doing and B you understand what you're
getting in on so Amen good question
thank you for joining us and let me use
you to teach this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income or $500,000 in common